Fairfax county is now a session
good morning all right do we have any
preliminary matters before the jury
comes out
wow okay that's a good day
all right if we could have the witness
Mr Beck come back to the stand is he
here or is he outside
all right just so we can be ready to go
hmm
all right so if you could come back to
the stand please thank you
and I think we're ready for the jury
that's fine thank you
um
just
all right you can have a seat Mr bent
good morning ladies and gentlemen all
right just a reminder Mr bet that you're
still under oath okay all right thank
you all right cross-examination
[Music]
good morning Mr Bat good morning you're
a full-time employee of Mr Depp correct
that's correct you've been working with
Mr Depp for about 15 years
give or take correct and you make a
salary for Mr Depp right I do and in
your role one of your top priorities is
to make sure Mr Depp is safe and that if
he's out he gets home safely correct
that's correct
and Mr Depp safety is a priority over
others that may be out with Mr Depp
correct
his safety along with the safety of the
people that are around him but Mr Depp's
safety is the top priority correct
correct
that just goes without saying right and
your role as his chief of security right
well as I said it's his safety but those
that are around him as well right but it
is he is a priority
and your job as Security is to remain
discreetly in the background right
correct you were not part of Mr Depp's
family
right correct you're not with him 24 7.
right correct and you weren't with him
24 7 when he was in a relationship with
Miss heard correct
correct and you obviously have no
personal knowledge of what happens when
you're not around correct that's correct
and you have no personal knowledge of
what happens behind closed doors with Mr
dab correct correct you weren't when Mr
Depp was in a relationship with Miss
heard you weren't traveling out of Los
Angeles as part of Mr Depp's security
correct
I did on one occasion What occasion was
that
uh we did a trip to Austin Texas
um
but other than that you didn't travel
outside of La as part of your security
when he was with Miss hurt correct
correct so you weren't in Australia in
March of 2015 right
correct you weren't on a plane flight
from Boston to Los Angeles in May of
2014 correct correct you didn't go to
the Bahamas with him correct correct you
didn't go to Tokyo with him and Miss
heard correct correct
you're around him almost every day when
he's in Los Angeles right almost picking
up food for him
yes pick up medicine for him
yes help coordinate visitors to his
house
correct or his houses
pick up groceries for him yes and you
let him into places like his residences
right
correct because he doesn't carry keys
for them right
correct you drive him places I do right
almost every time he leaves his property
he's being driven rather than driving
correct almost every time and you help
arrange that right yes your
responsibility one of them is to help
get him where he needs to go right
yes you've woken him up in the mornings
before
I have
and
yesterday I believe you testified that
sometimes Mr Depp would have just a
glass of wine or two right
yes and you testify that his demeanor
when he was slightly intoxicated was the
same as if he had had a glass of
sparkling water you remember giving that
testimony I do
fact is you've seen him much more
impaired than that right
I have you've you've seen him impaired
enough that you've had to help put him
to bed before right
I don't understand by putting him to bed
well there have been times when Mr Depp
was
um so impaired that you you had to get
up the stairs and open the bedroom doors
for him right
well that specific bedroom door and his
Los Angeles house it has a tricky lock
to it so it's you know there have been
times where I've gone upstairs and uh
maybe had a glass of water for him and
so I would have to open that door
for him correct right so you've you've
gotten him into bet you've got him some
water you've asked him if he needs
anything right correct in times when
he's been impaired correct
and times when he's just had breakfast
and some coffee and you've stayed with
him and during times when he's been
impaired there's times when you've
stayed with him until he lays down and
you tell him good night and that you'll
see him the next day right
I wouldn't stay with him I just would
say goodnight I'm going home and I'll
see you tomorrow or if I happen to have
a few days off I'll see you in a few
days
now yesterday
um
you've you've actually prevented people
from calling the police when Mr Depp's
Behavior after drinking was bothering
them haven't you
prevented people
[Music]
there was one time correct yeah and and
in that occasion uh Mr Depp and some
other people had
um had had a couple perfect bottles of
wine and pounded an entire bottle of
tequila right
I don't remember how much they had to
drink no
I know there was drinking going on Mr
Depp told you that they had had a couple
bottles of perfect wine and pounded an
entire bottle of tequila right I don't
remember that was some time ago Heather
can you pull up exhibit 892 please
Mr bet is this a text exchange that you
had with Mr Depp on September 1st 2017
at or 234 to 2 36 in the afternoon
um if you just give me a moment let me
put my glasses on sure take your time
have a hard time
okay much better
uh can you repeat that uh statement a
question sure sure my question was just
is this a text exchange that you and Mr
Depp had
um on September 1st 2017.
from 234 to 2 36 in the afternoon
objection your honor relevance the date
this is well after what's the relevance
of 2017. the relevance is that Mr vet
testified yesterday that he'd seen Mr
Depp have a glass or two of wine and
this is direct evidence to contradict
that I'll allow it all right thank you
okay
oh I'm sorry
um yeah according to the time stamp and
date that is a text message from Mr
debonair
and at 2 34 pm
Mr Depp texts you
Stakes were excellent pondering though
we'll likely have dinner here Stakes
were excellent a couple of bottles of
perfect wine we then pounded an entire
bottle of tequila three exclamation
points then the savagery commenced
two exclamation points good morning
three exclamation points did I read that
right you did and there's an X and
faccia after that okay and then you you
told Mr
Depp that you prevented you said I
prevented them from calling popo
objection your honor hearsay
improper impeachment that's for the
context of the text and when he was he
testified that he had prevented him
thank you
so then Mr bet you texted Mr debt back
two minutes later and you said I
prevented them from calling popo glad
you had fun you mean dinner in room or
restaurant do you see that I do and you
sent that text to Mr Depp correct I did
and by popo you mean police correct
that's correct okay
um you told him that you were glad he
had fun right
right
your honor permission to move for
admission of exhibit 892 and permission
to publish
our objection is relevance this is well
past the relationship between Mr Depp
and misheard
it was just used for impeachment why
would it come into evidence well it's Mr
Depp's
um
Mr Depp's statements about what he did
uh when he pounded an entire bottle of
tequila and the savagery that commence
go toward his his use of alcohol that's
much greater than in 2017. I'll sustain
the objection thank you your honor
you're aware that Mr Depp has used
drugs right I am and you've you've
helped facilitate Mr Depp's drug use on
occasion correct I haven't I'm sorry I
haven't you have not I have not Heather
can you pull up exhibit 967 please
[Music]
Mr bet feel free to take the time that
you need to to review this document
familiarize yourself with it
um but my first question for you is just
is this a text exchange that you had
with Mr Depp on June 12 2019.
June 12th
according to these transcripts yeah it
has uh my name and his name on there
right
um
and if it starts at the bottom and goes
up correct
no I'm sorry I wasn't paying attention
to the time stamps that's okay hard to
orient yourself with these sometimes
okay uh at the bottom yeah I do see 6 12
19 at uh 1 50 P.M
and then
the more recent texts are as you go up
the page right correct
so in the in the bottom text you're
telling Mr Depp that some people are are
at his house visiting and you say
um they'll be at the pool hearsay
also relevance this is 2019 which
he just testified that he hadn't helped
facilitate Mr Depp's drug use so this is
for impeachment and this is you got to
read the text and context to see how it
impeaches him all right we could come
short approach please
thank you
foreign
Mr bet you communicate with Mr Depp
through texts correct I do that's your
primary way of communicating with him
well not primary I mean if I happen to
be in his presence we'll communicate
sure but in terms of written
Communications texting is the way that
you guys primarily communicate right
correct and you that's the same thing
that you the same way that you
communicate primarily with his other
employees or with his family as well
right yes you have a practice of
deleting all of your texts with them at
the end of the day or week correct
that's correct so there wouldn't be
texts from his time uh when he was in a
relationship with Amber Heard that you
have possession of correct that's
correct
you've never seen Amber do something
that you would call physically violent
or an assault of Mr Depp correct
other than when I testified that she
threw a water bottle or a plastic cup in
his Direction
but that you wouldn't consider that
physically violent or an assault of him
correct
well in California it's a solid if you
go to attempt to swing or throw
something at somebody even if you don't
hit them
all right
that's all right
Mr bet do you remember giving a
deposition in this case
I do
and you were under oath for that
deposition correct
I was and I asked you a number of
questions right
you asked me several yes I did and um
if you can turn to page 111 of this
transcript please
it's on page 28 of the the document I'm
sorry
okay
and if you look at line 22 the last line
and then heading over to page 112. you
see that got it and in in your
deposition
um I asked you this question and you
gave this answer question so is it fair
to say that while you've seen misheard
yell and get emotional toward Johnny
you've never seen her do something that
you would call physically violent or
assault of Johnny answer correct did I
read that right
eat it
I'd like to turn to May 21st 2016.
that was the incident that we talked
about last night right before you we
adjourned for the day correct correct
you and Mr uh Jerry judge brought Mr
Depp over to the penthouses at the
Eastern Columbia building that night
right we did and you knew that he was
going there to speak with Amber correct
and gather some belongings your
understanding was that Mr Depp was going
over there because they both wanted to
talk and calm everything down right
objection calls for speculation as to
what Miss heard wanted
I'll sustain the objection
s Mr Depp told you that he and Amber
were going to talk it out and talk about
what's going on correct
and he had wine in the car on the way
over I believe he testified yesterday
right
he did have a glass one and
um it's I think you testified as
possible he had been drinking during the
day before you brought him over there
correct
correct I saw him with a wine glass
after his meeting when he came out into
the hallway
and when you
um no I'm sorry during the day before
you picked him up to go over to the
Eastern Columbia building it's possible
he'd been drinking correct
well we were at a meeting he he did have
a glass of wine in his hand so I presume
he was drinking okay and when you
arrived at the Eastern Columbia building
you can't say one way or the other
whether Mr Depp was carrying wine with
him into the building right
I can't remember
you and Mr judge let him into Penthouse
three and were in there for just a
minute or two
um
before you exited Penthouse 3 correct
yes give or take
and then you stayed outside in the
hallway of Penthouse three for a bit
right
a short period of time correct I think
you testified yesterday like 10 minutes
is that right yeah give her two
um and then you from there you went from
the hallway outside of Penthouse three
to Hen House five the the storage area
where you had a couch and a TV and that
sort of thing you testified about right
that's correct is that also known as the
guard shack
a modified version of the guard shack
it's just a place for us as I testified
yesterday to you know rest or have lunch
or some coffee sometimes called the
cubby hole is that right
uh we might have called that that I I
can't remember what okay just to orient
us Heather can you please pull up
plaintiff's exhibit 116.
and your honor I believe this has
already been entered into evidence
yes it's inevitable
can you can you rotate that please
counterclockwise
okay and then maybe just blow it up
please
and you're on a permission to publish if
it thank you oh thank you
um
so Mr bet if if you just to orient us am
I correct in saying that the
um well could you put your finger just
on the the guard shack area of Penthouse
five please
the diagram the schematics is kind of
off because the way Broadway is set up
it doesn't coincide with the way the
buildings were but I can
make an attempt to show you where the
yeah just I think I think the screen
will make a Mark if you show on it okay
I mean I'm having a um
thank you
okay okay um so this is I'd say right in
this area right here okay is it showing
up
because there would be elevators to the
right it is okay yep yep that's showing
up okay so that's down the hall from
outside of Penthouse three right correct
and you s you stayed in that guard shack
for
um I believe you said five to ten
minutes is that right yes so if you
spent about 10 minutes outside Penthouse
three and then five to ten minutes
um inside pen inside the guard shack you
say you were at the building for what a
total of 30 minutes or so
it could have been a little bit longer
it could have been 40 it could have been
closer to an hour it was um quite some
time ago but you're you're fairly
confident with 40 minutes to an hour
around that time frame correct
and you were you said that you arrived
at the building sometime between 7 15
and 7 45 is that what you said yesterday
yeah what's your best guess
it would be an estimate guess maybe
more towards eight-ish but again it
could have been 7 30 I just okay
more towards eight-ish
all right and so you stayed in the guard
shack for five to ten minutes and then
you left the guard shack and headed back
up the hall toward the door of Penthouse
three right yes and at some point you
heard Amber shouting and you let
yourself into Penthouse three
right that's correct the closest you've
got to Amber when you went into
Penthouse three was 15 to 20 feet right
around that correct
and you were in
um Penthouse 3 for just about 30 seconds
to a minute before you left again with
Mr Depp right
around that time frame you don't
remember what Miss heard was wearing do
you
I know and you can't remember if she was
crying when you saw her right
I didn't see her crying you can't
remember if she was crying right I just
said I didn't see her crying she could
have been crying right objection calls
for speculation and asked an answer
yeah it's a different question well I'll
sustain that objection the next question
and you can't remember she had any
makeup on or not right
if she did she had very little
you just can't remember if she did right
I mean yeah I mean it's possible but it
was a long time ago
turn to page 160 please
in your deposition
okay that'd be page 40 as well page 40
yes yes sir
and on line one
um I see the question did Miss heard
have any you couldn't tell if she was
wearing any makeup right your answer was
I can't remember if she had any makeup
on or not did I read that right you did
um
and you don't know what you have no
personal knowledge of what transpired in
Penthouse 3 while you were outside of it
that evening correct I don't and you
have no personal knowledge of whether
Amber had a phone thrown in her face by
Johnny Depp that evening correct
I don't because you weren't there right
that's correct so you left Penthouse
three and then you went into Penthouse
five at Mr Depp's insistence that he'd
get into Penthouse five right that's
correct and he was agitated at this time
right
I'm sorry I you said I went into
Penthouse three or Penthouse five at
this time I'm sorry you left you left
Penthouse three after 30 to 60 seconds
with Mr Depp and Mr judge and you went
to Penthouse five right correct and
that's because Mr Depp was demanding to
get into Penthouse five right yes and Mr
Depp was agitated at this time right
yeah I'd say he was agitated and you one
of the reasons that you could tell that
he was agitated was because this wasn't
the first time you had seen him agitated
right
come on now
Mr Depp told you to let him into
Penthouse five and you did that right
yes and when he left Penthouse three to
go to Penthouse five you can't remember
if he had wine in his hand or not
correct
I can
I'm sorry I can't cannot cannot and when
he walked into Penthouse five inside
were Rocky Pennington her fiance Josh
Drew and another woman and a dog right
that's correct and Mr Depp told them to
get out of his Penthouse right
yes and they exited right they did and
you can't remember one way or the other
whether Mr Depp knocked anything off the
table in any of the penthouses right
it's possible he did
um but I can't remember
did you or Mr judge just to be clear did
you or Mr judge destroy any property or
knock anything off tables in any of the
penthouses that evening
no
you have no personal knowledge of
whether or not Mr Depp was violent to
misheard at times when you weren't
around them correct
I have no knowledge and misheard may
have suffered injuries at the hands of
Mr Depp over the years that you didn't
witness or you didn't see correct
correct
I'd like to to
End by just just taking a look at the
videos of you entering and exiting the
building I believe Heather could you
pull up exhibit 672
in your honor I believe
um
I believe that these were part of Mr
Patterson's
um deposition and that they've been
admitted I do have a 672 admitted
correct yes that's correct okay and the
next one will be 666 just to confirm all
right we have that as well thank you
your honor
Heather could you play this starting at
uh one well actually before we start do
you see this on your screen uh Mr bet I
do and you see the time stamp
um
that at the bottom that's that shows
what time the the
camera uh the video was taken correct I
see the temps the time stamp and the
date okay let's go ahead and play this
Heather
start at 155.
that's you in that black and white shirt
right
that's me
that's Mr Depp in the Hat
correct and that's Mr judge to his left
correct
in this video is when you're entering
the Eastern Columbia building to take
him to Penthouse three correct
uh correct
so it's actually a good bit earlier than
you testified to right it's at 702. if
I'm converting military time to
well that's what the time stamps says I
mean I don't know how it was calibrated
and so forth but according to the screen
it does say 1902 hours which is 702. 702
PM right correct on May 21st 2016. yeah
right okay Heather you can take that
down please please pull up exhibit 666.
foreign
and you see that the time stamp on this
video is
well let's go ahead and play the video
first
and that's you on the right again right
it is and that's Mr judge in the middle
right yes and that's Mr Depp on the left
correct yes
and the time stamp on this video is 2029
or 8 29 p.m right that's correct so you
were actually in in the Eastern Columbia
building for about an hour and a half
that evening right well according to
these uh time stamps yes it does say
that it didn't seem like it was that
long
I have nothing further thank you all
right thank you redirect
Mr bet you previously testified that
when you left Penthouse three and went
into Penthouse five
um who was inside that Penthouse When
you entered with Mr Depp
uh Josh Drew uh an unknown female and a
little dog was Miss Pennington inside
Penthouse 3 when you entered with Mr
Depp I'm sorry you said Penthouse five
didn't you am I getting my numbers
you're right my apologies let me start
over
when you left Penthouse three and went
into Penthouse five
who was inside let's try this again okay
uh Josh Drew an unknown female and a
cute little dog
where was Miss Pennington was she inside
Penthouse 3 when you entered
or Penthouse five When you entered she
was not in Penthouse five no where
where was the last place you saw Miss
Pennington on May 21st
standing next to miss heard in Penthouse
number three
I think there's been also a little bit
of confusion about April 21st 2016 and
May 21st 2016. so let's start with April
21st 2016.
what a question just to the the
Miss Vasquez testifying
I'm just trying to orient the witness
I'll try to limit that
um
where was Mr Depp on April 21st 2016.
on April 21st he was at a meeting in his
Production Office okay and I believe you
testified previously that you saw him
holding a glass of wine is that right
correct okay
um did he appear intoxicated to you
after that meeting
he didn't
I'm sorry I didn't catch that he did not
he did not okay
now on May 21st 2016 was Mr Depp
drinking wine that day
he did have wine with him yes correct
and at what point Did You observe Mr Deb
with wine on May 21st 2016.
um he probably had it in the car with
him when we were driving down
and
um he could have finished it prior to us
walking uh to Penthouse three
did Mr Depp based on your observations
Mr bet appear intoxicated to you on May
21 2016 before he arrived to the Eastern
Columbia building
he didn't
he did not he did not
whoever observed anything that made you
concerned for misheard safety
objection Foundation
and leading
out loud if you can answer it
I did not
what if anything did You observe that
made you concerned for Mr Depp's safety
from the injuries I saw on his face when
on a few occasions I took photos of him
nothing further thank you
[Music]
subject to recall correct okay all right
so you're free to go or you have a seat
in the in the courtroom it's up to you
all right thank you thank you you have a
good day sir
all right your next witness uh thank
your honor plaintiff calls Keenan Wyatt
okay Keenan Wyatt could you spell that
name for me
k-e-e-n-a-n last name Wyatt w-a
w-y-a-t-t all right thank you so much
bye
um
Pearson
Mississippi
truthfully in this case and penalty of
law
yes sir
good morning Mr Wyatt morning would you
please State your full name for the
record Keenan Wyatt Mr Wyatt where do
you live Thousand Oaks California
what do you do for a living excuse me
I'm a sound technician on feature films
how long have you been a sound
technician on feature over 35 years
would you please briefly describe for
the jury what a sound technician on
film's work does well the uh technically
just do the uh dialogue recording while
on on the set so it's as clean as
possible
do you know Johnny Depp yes I do
how do you know Mr doubt uh
I've known Johnny for over 25 years and
we're good friends
have you ever worked with Mr Depp yes I
have
for how many of Mr Depp's films have you
worked with him as the sound technician
uh to dozens of dozens of films would
you please just name a few of them for
the jury if you can remember uh I've
done the five Pirate of the Caribbean
movies Alice in Wonderland
uh Rum Diary Charlie and the Chocolate
Factory Ninth Gate
Lone Ranger number of films what part
did Mr Depp play in the five Pirates of
the Caribbean movies Captain Jack
Sparrow
are you are Mr Wyatt are you currently
employed by Mr Depp no
have you ever been employed by Mr Depp
no
have you ever been paid by Mr death no
have you ever worked for any of Mr
Depp's companies yes I've worked for
infinitive Nile
when was the last time you worked for an
infinitive Nile uh last time I was there
was probably 2017 I worked on a contract
basis with them not as an employee and
would you very briefly describe for the
jury what work you did for infinitive
Nile in 2017. I ran the media library
with them did some archiving recording
editing things like that
how would you describe briefly your
working relationship with Mr Depp in the
25 years or so that you've worked
together uh Johnny's great to work with
on Films he's he always comes very
prepared and uh
knows what he wants to do and makes it
for a fun day when we're shooting
with what directors have you and Mr Depp
work together oh many directors
um
but we've done several films multiple
films with multiple directors like uh
Tim Burton Gore verbinski Rob Marshall
we've done multiple films with them why
did you and Mr Depp work with those
directors more than once johnny makes it
easy to work with uh Foundation
your honor he's laid the foundation he's
worked with Mr Depp for 25 years on more
than a more than 10 feature films and
relevance
thank you your honor
why did you
um
why did you and Mr Depp work with those
directors more than more than once well
he he uh the directors like working for
him he comes with they're saying move to
strike your honor he uh you just uh
allowed the question oh loud go ahead
uh johnny makes it easy to work with
he's uh he comes prepared he knows what
he wants to do with the characters and
he collaborates very well with the
directors
is Pirates five one of the feature films
on which you work together with Mr Depp
yes
was Mr Depp ever late to the set on
Pirates five yes
do you know why Mr Depp was late on
those occasions
uh well arguing going on between him and
Amber objection hearsay Foundation
sustain the objection
what base um strike that
did you communicate with crew members on
the set of pirates five every day yes
was Mr Depp's lateness a problem for the
crew objection calls for hearsay all
right stain as to what the crew may have
told him well I was just asking the
threshold question of whether he had
spoken with the crew right I'll sustain
the objection
putting aside occasional lateness on the
set of pirates five
was production of pirates 5 ever
suspended for any period of time
objection
for hearsay Foundation
how he knew it you want to lay the
foundations how did you know whether
production of pirates 5 was ever
suspended I was on the film I was
working on the film so okay
so I know it was suspended probably for
two or three weeks and why was it
suspended for two or three weeks uh
Johnny had to go back to Los Angeles
because his finger had been cut off tip
of his finger had been cut off do you
have any understanding of how Mr Depp's
or the top of Mr Depp's finger was cut
off
and I believe you testify that
production was suspended for a period of
two or three weeks did there come a time
when Mr Depp returned from Los Angeles
to Australia for completion of the field
of the shooting of pirates five yes he
did
who is Sean Bailey
uh he's an executive at Disney
after Mr Depp returned to the set of
pirates five in Australia what if any
interactions Did You observe between Mr
Depp and Mr Daly uh Sean had come to set
one day and uh sat and talked with
Johnny for a while and they talked about
collaborating and doing some stuff in
the future was it a friendly
conversation absolutely yes
has Mr Depp ever worn an earpiece in any
of the many movies uh in which you've
worked with him yes
for what purpose are earpieces generally
used by actors on sets
well I've worked with your honor first
of all relevance Foundation
what's the relative may we approach your
honor okay sure
thank you
Mr Wyatt has Mr Depp ever worn an
earpiece in any of the movies in which
you've worked with him rejection leading
a lot
yes he has
when was the first time you used an
earpiece with Mr Depp
first time we used it was on a movie he
was directing called The Brave
um
we were doing a scene with uh Marlon
Brando who wears an earpiece for
receiving his dialogue
I'll allow it it's fine good
Marlin uses an earpiece for uh
for his dialogue and
it was a long shooting day and we let uh
Johnny as the Director let Marlin go
after we shot Marlin's section of the
film
and then to for Johnny's character to
act against something other than just a
blank nothing we put Marlin's
performance in an earpiece in into
Johnny so he could act up against
Marlin's performance
did Mr Depp ever use an earpiece for
some other purpose other than listening
to Mr Brando's dialogue after that we
started using an earpiece all the time
um
where Johnny would listen to music while
acting
um we would play all different kinds of
music depending on the character
he was uh he was playing he and I would
talk about it beforehand and
you sometimes be classical sometimes it
would be Rock sometimes it would be
Blues it depended on the character
to what extent if any did you and Mr
Depp use that process in other movies on
which you work together we use that on
every movie
Mr Wyatt on those occasions in addition
to feeding Mr Depp music did you ever
read lines to him yes
why did you read lines to Mr Depp
um Johnny typically likes to go into
makeup in the morning and write his own
dialogue and rewrite his dialogue
so sometimes
there's not enough time to always to
remember you know to remember the lines
and learn them so I would remind him in
his ear sometimes while while music was
playing at the same time
and Mr White and your long experience
working with Mr Depp on Films how would
you describe his level of preparedness
on the set he's absolutely prepared he
knows what he wants the character to be
he collaborates with the act with the
director on what
um what his ideas are but he always
comes very prepared
and Mr Wyatt during your long
relationship with Mr Depp what if any
opportunity have you had to observe his
sense of humor
quite often
how would you describe to the jury Mr
Depp's sense of humor
uh he likes like a British humor he's
he's uh you know um
sometimes a little dark maybe he likes
plays on Words you know that sort of
thing Monty Python Monty Python there's
a there's a show in England called the
fast show which he used to love watching
Mr Wyatt what if any relationship do you
have with Mr Depp outside of your
working relationship
uh we're close uh I used to uh
after a film sometimes he'd call and
would go on vacation with uh he and his
family
on what occasions would you go on
vacation with Mr Depp and his family
well he would call after after a film
and he would be going away with the the
kids in Vanessa and he would say hey you
know we're going we're going to the
island would you come with me and stuff
or we're going to France would you come
along and sure why not would you please
uh give the jury Vanessa's full name uh
Vanessa Paradis and would you please
tell the jury who she is uh she is the
mother of Johnny's two kids Jack and
Lily Rose
and Mr Wyatt uh on how many occasions if
you can recall did you accompany Mr Depp
uh Miss parody and Johnny's two children
on vacation several times
did on those several occasions where you
accompanied them on vacation did you
ever observe Mr Depp and Vanessa
interact with each other sure yes would
you please tell the jury what you
observed
they were they were a loving couple and
everything was fine yeah it was a family
did you ever hear or see Mr Depp yell or
raise his voice at Vanessa Paradis the
mother of his children not that I recall
did you ever on any occasion see Mr Depp
physically abuse Vanessa never
and I believe you testified Mr Wyatt
that Mr Depp's and Miss Paradis children
Lily Rose and Jack were there on those
vacations is that correct yes did you
have occasion to observe Mr Depp's
interactions with his children sure yes
would you please describe for the jury
very briefly Mr Depp's interactions with
his children Jack and Lily wrote he was
a very loving father he used to do stuff
with the kids all the time going
swimming at the island and teaching them
scuba diving and you know
just drawing a lot of drawing doing
artwork
did he ever yell or raise his voice at
his children not that I recall nothing
that stands out no
Mr Wyatt on what if any occasions have
you seen Mr Depp drink alcohol
oh we would drink we'd drink
alcohol quite often
and on those occasions in which you had
alcohol with Mr Depp how if it all did
his behavior change
I I don't remember it changing at all I
don't remember him changing
it didn't make him angry no no
sleepy
have you ever seen Mr Depp use drugs
uh I've seen him take pills
um don't know what they were I wouldn't
know what they were but
that's all
based on your observations when you have
seen him taking pills how if at all did
the taking of pills affect his behavior
I I didn't see any change in Johnny I
didn't I don't recall anything changing
Mr Wyatt do you know the defendant in
this case Ms Amber Heard yes
when did you first meet Miss hurt uh on
the set of Rum Diary
on how many occasions if at all did you
see misheard after that
um several
several times would you please describe
for the jury very briefly your
relationship with Ms heard after you saw
her the first few times I mean I don't
really have a relationship with her we
didn't we didn't sit and talk I didn't
it didn't hang out with her or anything
like that
did there come a time when you became
aware that Mr Depp and misheard were
romantically involved yes
how often did you see Mr Depp after he
started the Romantic relationship with
Miss hurt
oh I don't recall I didn't I I didn't
see him that often but
I don't recall how often how often that
I didn't see him
I didn't seem that much how often were
you together to strike that how often
did you interact with Mr Depp and
misheard when the two of them were
together
uh just only occasionally did I see him
I mean we we would uh I would leave him
alone let him have his time with with
Amber I wasn't into interfering
and and and on those occasions where you
interacted with Mr Depp and misheard as
a couple
uh did you ever hear Mr Depp yell at or
raise his voice to misheard no
on what occasions if any did he ever
raise his hand to or otherwise
abuse Miss hurt I've never seen him be
violent towards anybody
and if we could uh did there come switch
gears here did there come a time
in May 2014 when you traveled with Mr
Depp and misheard by private plane from
Boston to Los Angeles yes
who else was on that Boston plane flight
uh it was Amber and Johnny uh Stephen
uh Savannah and Jerry judge and myself
and would you please tell the jury who
is Stephen uh Steven deuters is Johnny's
assistant
who is Savannah Savannah was um Amber's
assistant
and I think that jury has heard the name
Jerry judge but if you could please
explain to the jury again who Jerry
judge is Jerry judges Johnny's security
Mr Wyatt why were you on that flight
that night
I don't know the exact circumstances of
that flag I didn't travel with the two
of them that often I was probably headed
back to Los Angeles to see my daughter
and before you got on the flight how did
you arrive at the airport that night uh
we came in a car
when you say you came in the car with
whom did you come in the car uh it was
uh Jerry Stephen Nathan Johnny and
myself and and who is Nathan Nathan is
uh is Johnny's other assistant Nathan
Holmes
what if any alcohol or drugs did you see
Mr Depp take while on the car ride to
the airport
on the car ride I don't I don't recall
any anything being taken we uh Johnny I
know had called Jack during the car ride
to talk to him to tell me we're on our
way and we were listening to the World
Cup that was going on at the time and if
you could just remind the jury who Jack
is Jack is Johnny's a little boy
when you and Mr Depp and the security
Personnel arrived at the plane who if
anyone was there at the plane This Plane
had come from New York with Amber and
Savannah already on it
what if anything did You observe about
Miss heard's behavior on that Boston
flight
uh well she was given Johnny the cold
shoulder being quiet
um and uh you know seemed pouty
what if any conversation did you have
with a misheard on the flight well at
one point I went up to her and said uh
something to the effect of you know he
cares about you and all of a sudden she
snapped and started yelling at me how
dare you talk to me get away from me
yeah so I went back to a seat and minded
my own business
when she said those things to you
um
would you describe the tone of her voice
if you remember it she she was abruptly
loud it was a quiet plane all of a
sudden it got very loud
and I believe you testified you went
back to your seat or you moved um
what happened next
uh
Johnny had said something to her like
you know don't talk to my friend that
way and I I just stayed in my seat and
finish the rest of the flight
and after you went back to your seat to
what extent if any were you able to see
Mr Depp and Miss hurt uh
I was able to see them very clearly
what if any violence or physical
altercation Did You observe between Mr
Depp and misheard once you'd gone back
to your seat I I've never seen Johnny be
violent towards anybody
to what extent if any Did You observe Mr
Depp or misheard hit kick or throw
anything at each other on the plane no I
don't recall that at all
Mr Wyatt was Mr Depp consuming any
alcohol in that flight sure yes did he
seem intoxicated
seem intoxicated I no he seemed like
Johnny now he seemed normal
did there come a time Mr Wyatt when you
learned that Mr Depp and misheard were
getting married to each other yes
how did you find out about that there
would be a wedding
I was at the infinitum office and uh
Christie came to me and said hey uh
I'm just asking it's not for the proof
I'm just asking him how he found out
about the wedding
all right what's the relevance may we
approach okay
foreign
Mr Wyatt did you end up attending the
wedding yes I did where was that where
did the wedding take place there's two
weddings uh one at uh
one of Betty Sue's house
um Johnny's mom's house and then another
one on the island yeah one on the island
I did not attend what if anything did
You observe at the Los Angeles ceremony
that you attended at uh
Betty Sue that this is mother's house
um it was all very quick I mean we all
found out about it at the last moment
um
it was a bit of confusion Johnny had a
friend from out of town and she wasn't
sure what was going on
um little Jack didn't understand what
was going on yeah sustain as other
people go ahead
what if anything did You observe about
Ms herd's demeanor at the ceremony
she was very happy go lucky she was all
dressed up all of her friends were
nicely dressed up and ready for a
wedding
have you ever in the course of your
interactions with Miss heard ever seen
any marks injuries or bruises on her I
have not no
during the decades that you have known
Mr Depp to what extent if any are you
aware of any woman other than misheard
accusing him of abuse
I'll allow it
I've never seen Johnny abuse anybody
ever
thank you very much Mr Wyatt that's all
I have right now let me go ahead and
take our break all right let's go ahead
and take our morning break for 15
minutes do not say anything uh to do not
talk to me about the case and don't look
up anything if a juror needs to address
something to me please write it down and
give it to the deputy okay all right
thank you you're excused 15 minutes
foreign
Mr White since you're still in the
middle of your testimony you can't
discuss the case or your testimony with
the attorneys or with Mr deaf at this
time okay all right thank you let's just
come back and let's make it 11 20. okay
we'll come back 11 20. all right thank
you all right
thank you
all right we're ready for the jury
okay
okay yes
no
no
no
foreign
cross-examination
thank your honor now Mr White you
testified that you've been a sound
technician for pretty much most of your
career right okay and let's go to that
Marlon Brando that he used an earpiece
for his lines to be fed to him correct
at that time and when was that when was
the brave filmed
uh
mid 90s okay and so ever since then Mr
Depp has thought it was a good idea and
has used an earpiece correct he has used
in your piece yes okay and you're the
person who controls what goes into his
earpiece is that correct okay so it
could be music it can be lines it can be
anything right yes okay and you have
been his sound technician since the
1990s all the way up through at least
two six 2016. correct there's been a
couple of us yes okay but but you
actually have been on almost all his
movies haven't you been on most of them
probably okay and in fact not only are
you his personal sound technician but
you are named in his contracts as his
sound technician correct I don't know
that okay well let's pull up
exhibit number
let's go to 633
and I'm going to show you what has been
marked as defendant's exhibit 633 and
it's the contract for Pirates of the
Caribbean from August 2022. do you see
that
uh objection Locker Foundation I'm sorry
lack of foundation I didn't get I didn't
get his answer out loud go ahead
I see it it says August uh 2002. let's
turn to page 16.
actually the one before that that's two
before that I think
there we go
do Seward says location assistant yes
okay and if you go down it has your name
specifically on there does it not say
Keenan Wyatt yes okay and on this
particular one it has Sam sarker and
Keenan Wyatt do you see that yes but
eventually it just became Keenan white
in all the contracts right I do not know
I don't know okay and then as part of
this in each of Mr Debb's contracts he
had what you were going to get paid
correct
I don't know what's in his car okay well
on this one it was
1428 per hour correct like like a
foundation your honor all right well
well he doesn't know this contract if
you want to uh okay it's a different
question well
you on every one of his contracts had an
hourly rate and a guarantee of at least
60 hours a week right calls for
speculation like a foundation surely he
has to know how he was getting paid if
you want to ask that question do you
know how you were getting paid on each
of these films yes okay I get paid
through a payroll company from the
production companies okay and these were
all negotiated by Mr Depp correct no for
his company paid by the uh the union
sets the rate for me right but you're
aware that Mr Depp has negotiated it and
put you into his contract lack of
foundation calls for speculation I'll
allow that answer if you can answer it
sorry you're aware question again you're
aware that Mr Depp has put you into each
of his contracts including how much you
get paid in all of your perks right I
see it here but um when I'm hired by a
production company I get paid by the
production company at my union rate for
the job that I'm doing that's not the
rate I make when I'm working on a
production okay uh all right well let's
uh let's stay in this one just for a
minute and then we'll take a look at a
couple more because you ended up with a
lot higher rate pretty soon
um but you also had your airfare paid
for correct for travel yes you also were
put up in the same hotel as Mr Depp if
he was in a hotel correct uh not
necessarily all the time right and if he
was in a house then you got a comparable
hotel close by right I got a place to
stay wherever we were filming yes and it
was comparable comparable to Johnny it
was a it was a positive it was a a nice
hotel wasn't it
um yeah I mean Productions we usually
stayed at nice hotels okay so is it is
it your testimony that you didn't know
that you were named specifically in the
terms of your compensation and your
benefits were in every single one of Mr
Depp's contracts objection asked and
answered several times your honor it has
not and I had to allow it I did not know
it was in okay the contract next
question
okay I'm gonna let's go take a look real
quick I'm gonna flip over to
eight eight five five
and this is a contract December 4 2008.
with Paramount Pictures
for Rango do you recall that yes and you
were his sound technician there correct
yes and if we turn to page 12 which is
the second one
if you look down there your name is
right there you're designated as sound
technician correct
do you see that yes all right and then
let's flip to the next page
and that has
3 500 per week correct lack of
foundation
do you remember getting 3 500 a week I
get whatever the weekly rate is for the
union position that I'm doing I don't
know at this time I don't recall what
the rate was I don't know if that's what
I got or not um but I got what the union
set as my minimum rate okay and again
you didn't know that Mr Depp negotiated
this into his contract okay and then if
we go down a little bit further here it
has you uh round trip class
Transportation coach class
transportation
you see that yes and then it has hotel
accommodations and per diem on the same
basis as the crew of the picture on this
one correct yes so we were in Rango was
in Los Angeles so none of that would
have right so it was a lot easier then
let's jump to plaintiff's exhibit 842
and this is Pirates of the Caribbean
July 2014 this would be for five right
trying to lack of foundation these are
contracts to which Mr Wyatt was not a
party
you're either it's not offered to prove
the truth of the contract and what is it
offered for
what's all right well let me ask it this
way
um for pirates five
were you you were in what was your hotel
accommodations I was staying in a
condominium that the rest of the crew
was staying at okay and how much were
you getting paid on Pirates five
whatever the union minimum was for my
job do you have any idea what it was no
I don't recall okay I'd have to look it
up and were you aware that your
compensation and benefits were in Mr
Depp's Pirates contract no I did not
all right
now let's go to hybrids five in
particular I think you testified that Mr
Depp was was occasionally late laid a
lot to the set
I don't recall I mean he was late yes
there were days he didn't show up at all
weren't there uh could have been I don't
recall and there were days that he
didn't show up for six seven hours
correct yes okay and in fact he wasn't
showing up before Amber ever got to
Australia isn't that correct I don't I
don't know that do you recall him going
on a binge with Marilyn Manson for a few
days Jackson lack of foundation
call that
I'm sorry do you recall no I don't
recall you don't recall one way or the
other or you just no I didn't visit
Johnny when we were in Australia I don't
know
okay so you had a house I had a
condominium in town
so so you don't know what was causing
Johnny to be late or whether he was
taking a lot of alcohol and drugs
is that fair to say yes okay
and you said that you observed Johnny
Depp talking with Sean Bailey after he
came back and let's go to that you said
there was a two to three week delay in
fact it was closer to five to six weeks
wasn't it I don't recall what it was
significant when the entire crew has to
stop for that period of time projection
to Ms redhoff's testimony all right I'll
sustain the objection ask the question
it's pretty significant isn't it when
there's a delay
it's significant I don't think the film
completely shut down for all of that
they continued to shoot what they could
how many of the crew members were
impacted by Johnny not being able to be
there after he cut off after the finger
was cut off well there was the crew some
of the crew I'm sure still kept working
and shoot filming filming other scenes
without Johnny's character in it do you
know how many were impacted no I don't
do you know how much Disney was impacted
I don't okay so now you say when he came
back he had he collaborated with Sean
Bailey right and they were talking about
how they were going to get together on
something right yes did Johnny do
anything with Sean Bailey for the rest
of 2015
I don't know about that year
um but I know that uh they you know they
talked about collaborating and doing
something Sean and Johnny had worked out
Johnny working Mr White if you can just
answer your honor made the witness
please she asked the question you should
be did he collaborate in 2015. your
honor may he be allowed to yes please
let him finish the question answer sorry
go ahead Johnny and uh Sean put together
Johnny dressing up as Captain Jack and
addressing the crowd at the of Pirates
of the Caribbean ride your honor I'm
going to move to strike and ask you to
ask that to be strict and that is not
responsive to my question your honor she
asked him the question that's not the
question she asked him you want to ask
your question again yes did Mr Bailey
collaborate on any projects with Mr Depp
in 2015 after Pirates five the
the one I just said that the project of
that was a promotional project for was
it a film Caribbean was it filmed yeah I
think it was videotaped or filmed yes
was it a feature film that Disney movies
no all right let's go to 2016. did Sean
Bailey collaborate on any film project
with Mr Depp I don't know let's go to
2017. did Mr Bailey collaborate with Mr
Depp on any film project I don't know
the the timing of the other things no I
don't know if he did or not let's go to
2018. did Mr Bailey collaborate at all
with Mr Deb in 2018 I don't know
were you aware that Mr Bailey said that
he that Mr Depp was quote out and a
quote for pirate six in October of 2018.
hearsay all right how sustain is to hear
say okay let's pull up plaintiff's
exhibit 115.
you said plaintiff's 115. plane is 115.
oh defendants I'm sorry it's defendants
foreign
now this is an article
in October of 2018
do you recall seeing this article no you
never saw it I don't I don't read the I
don't read these stories and stuff like
that so would it be fair to say that you
don't know whether Mr Bailey had
determined that Mr debb would not be in
Pirate six as of October of 2018. I
don't I don't I don't know especially
based on this I don't I don't believe
this stuff anyway okay we can take that
down thank you
all right let's talk about
your visits with Vanessa and the kids
and Mr Depp you indicated you went on
some vacations with them correct yes
they were together for 14 years right
how many vacations did you go several I
don't I don't know all of them two three
probably more than that four
probably more than that I I don't know
half a dozen dozen okay we get to six
okay yeah six to twelve all right and
these are all vacations right after
filming yes okay so these are times
where everybody's having fun relaxing
it's not your regular yes you know
day-to-day grind that everybody goes
through right you okay now you have no
personal knowledge of whether Mr Depp
ever physically abused Vanessa Paradis
correct none that I ever saw right but
you have no no knowledge one way you
don't know do you none that I saw
correct right you don't know what went
on in their marriage and their
relationship when you weren't there
correct not when I was there no okay and
they split up right yes yes do you know
why they split up no I do not all right
you don't know if Mr Depp yelled or
raised his voice at Vanessa parody on a
daily basis when you weren't around do
you not when I wasn't around I don't
know right and then you were asked at
the very end by Mr
chew whether you had ever heard of any
woman accusing Mr Depp of violence and
you said you'd never heard of anyone
accusing Mr death of violence do you
recall that have you ever heard of Greg
Brooks
doesn't I don't know he's a manager on
the set from City of Lies who has filed
a lawsuit against Mr Dent for punishment
lack of foundation and object to miss
bretahof's speechifying
all right I I'll allow it he's good
I I don't I mean I don't know what
happened I've never seen it I've never
seen him be violent to anybody but but
you testified you'd never heard of that
so had you ever heard of Greg Brooks
accusing Mr Depp of punching him on the
set of city of Lies
yeah I mean I've heard it I don't know
any basis of it though so it's not true
that you've never heard of anyone
accusing Mr Depp of violence is it
I suppose not okay and you don't know
whether Mr Depp committed any domestic
abuse or violence on any of the women in
his relationships do you I never
witnessed it right you don't have
personal knowledge though do you only
what I've witnessed and I've never
witnessed it right you don't know what
went on
as doors
um now let's go to
the Boston plane
this was in May of 2014.
so you were in the car with Mr Depp
before he got on the plane yes how long
was he in that car how long were we in
the car yes
recall 45 minutes an hour maybe I don't
recall you sat on the tarmac for quite
some time before getting on the plane
didn't you I don't recall you don't
recall that no okay and is it your
testimony that Mr Depp wasn't drinking
anything while he was in the car not in
the car no
do we had Mr Depp been drinking anything
before he got into that I don't know I
wasn't with him before is it your
testimony that Mr Depp didn't take any
drugs while he was in the car not that I
recall
do you know whether he took any drugs
before he got in the car I wasn't with
him before he got in the car all right
and I think you testified in response to
the question that you didn't think that
he was intoxicated or high
no I mean he seemed like Johnny did he
take any Red Bulls that you socks took
any what Red Bulls Red Bulls uh I don't
know there was a there was occasion
where he would drink Red Bulls I don't
know if that was the same time or not
all right was he drinking vodka with any
Red Bulls I don't I don't know was he
drinking whiskey I don't know was he
taking cocaine I don't I've never seen
it no did you see any powders no
so you get on the airplane and it's your
testimony uh that
misheard
had a a bad tone of voice with Mr Depp
is that correct she had a bad tone of
voice with me
okay
um
in fact
wasn't Mr Depp saying pretty horrible
things to Ms heard I recall that like
get [ __ ] on set get [ __ ] with
[ __ ] James [ __ ] Franco did you
hear that I know
I don't did you hear him say at least
you [ __ ] liked it
did you hear him say I bet you slipped a
tongue in there and you liked it no did
you hear him say make references to
Amber's [ __ ] and asking her if her
[ __ ] was wet your honored like a
foundation or harassment we'll get did
you hear any of that no not really
objections
now you shared an oxygen tank with Mr
Depp on that Boston plane didn't you no
you don't recall Mr debb insisting that
that the flight attendant give him an
oxygen tank and the two of you used it
okay do you recall Mr debb drinking
champagne on the plane
I don't know what he was drinking I'm
sure I was having wine he could have
been having champagne do you remember
him drinking a couple bottles of
champagne I don't know how much
and it's your testimony that Mr debb
didn't kick Amber
I didn't see anything like that okay did
you see Mr Depp uh go to the back of the
plane and pass out and moan loudly I
don't recall that you don't recall that
either no okay
um can we pull up
defendants exhibit 245 please
and your honor I show no objection to it
in the the filings
so I'm going to move the admission of it
and I'm going to ask it to be published
you know any objection to 245. yes your
honor it's improper impeachment it's not
to him
all right if you want to approach we'll
see what your objections you have your
list of objections from your exhibits
foreign
Mr White are you aware that Mr duder's
uh
apologize to Amber for Mr Depp's conduct
afterwards lack of foundation hearsay
Runner I'll sustain the objection next
question okay
where did you go were you with Mr Depp
excuse me I apologize may we take this
down it's just under the witness but yes
thank you Ryan
okay were you did you leave the plane
with Mr death
uh I mean I got off the plane at the
same time I'm assuming I I went to my
own home okay and and what was Mr Depp's
state
I don't recall you don't recall if he
was passed out or not no
when you say you don't recall as you're
sitting here today under oath you
honestly can't remember if Mr Depp was
passed out when you left the plane
passed and answered your honor all right
uh this one time go ahead you can answer
sir there was lots of plane flights I
mean the only reason I remember this one
was because Amber yelled at me on that
flight
do you remember my question I I didn't I
don't recall
right I mean I could have gotten off the
plane and just left I don't know and Mr
dead
could have kicked Amber on that right
right well I asked an answer yeah not
that I saw okay and he could have passed
out no not that I recall okay
okay how many times were you with Amber
and Mr Depp together
I have no idea
no idea
well what would the circumstances have
been
invited over for something or other or
you know Johnny and I may have been
recording some music or something and
she was there uh
I don't know at work now you had a very
close personal relationship with Christy
dubrowski didn't you we're friends yes
yes and you were more than friends for
quite a few years with your honor
irrelevance may we approach it's
impeachment it's biased approach please
foreign
um
now you testify that the wedding that
you went to the one in Los Angeles
seemed to be a little rushed yes how
long were they engaged I
don't you have could have been
a pretty substantial period of time I
I okay so when you say rushed
we didn't know a wedding was going to
happen well and you said you were at the
offices of ad infinitum is that right
okay when you say we didn't know any
wedding was going to happen
who's we
uh several of the people at the wedding
didn't know okay okay now did you know
what Amber's film schedule was no
did you know whether she was out of town
coming back in and leaving again I did
not know did you know what Johnny's film
schedule was I probably knew we were off
because you were his sound technician
right we were starting a film reading a
film or whatever yes okay and when did
you leave for pirates five I don't
recall when what did was he's filming
right before Pirates five I don't recall
okay so as soon after they did the Los
Angeles wedding they went to the Bahamas
correct I don't remember the time
difference but you didn't go to that
wedding no do you know how many people
did no do you know how much organization
was involved in getting that wedding
together in the Bahamas no
no do you know whether uh
do you know
well okay I guess you don't know so I
guess I shouldn't ask you then so as a
practical matter you don't know about
any of the communications between Mr
Depp and Ms heard for when they wanted
the wedding to take place correct
correct okay thank you I have no further
questions okay
your honor I just have a few sure
redirect
Mr Wyatt You testified earlier that you
worked with Mr Depp as his sound
technician on more than 10 feature films
is that correct correct have you ever
worked on feature films as a sound
technician or in any other capacity on
Films without Mr Depp yes I have
on those instances and those films not
involving Mr Depp
were your travel costs covered yes they
are
were your hotel costs covered yes they
are was your airfare covered yes
were those arrangements handled in any
way different from the films on which
you worked with Mr Depp no
what was your understanding of why Mr
Depp was late on the set to Pirates five
so you use your microphone
objection your honor he's already
testified he doesn't know and he wasn't
there with him and he doesn't know
directly related to the Cross how loud
go ahead
sorry say it again what was your
understanding of why Mr Depp was late
occasionally on the set of pirates five
uh my understanding was he was having
arguments with uh amber
and the wedding
that you attended or the ceremony in Los
Angeles that was right before Mr Depp
was to start filming Pirates five
correct
yes is that one of the reasons Amber
wanted to be married right then
objection
Mr Wyatt
you've known Mr Depp for a long time
correct yes and you've worked you've
worked with him for a long time yes
Has any woman other than Miss heard
ever accused him of raising a hand to
her objection your honor he's already
asked that before
thank you Mr White and thank you your
honor nothing further all right
just subject to recall
all right sir since you're subject to
recall you cannot discuss your testimony
with anybody and do not watch anything
uh in the news media at this time and
you maybe recalled at a later date okay
okay all right thank you sir you have a
good day your excuse for today thank you
all right
ladies and gentlemen we have a few
housekeeping matters to take care of and
also I know the cafeteria was a little
rough yesterday so I'm going to go ahead
and give you an extended lunch today
until two o'clock so just do not discuss
the case with anybody and don't do any
outside research and we'll see you back
here at 2 p.m okay if you just go with
deputies
okay
email that I gave you
tell hallucin
ations
all right okay so you said she had some
housekeeping matters to take I'm not
aware of any um
we'd like to speak with you about some
new videos if you have a moment I'm
happy to chat with them but okay so you
don't need me for that oh okay I thought
you needed me for that so so you want to
get some extended one so I get an
extended lunch okay well what I'm gonna
do
um just to let you know actually if you
approach the bench
all right